we just want to know uh how was your day
today how was my day
yes sir you understand what i'm saying
yes i'm native american
you understand what i'm saying yes you
understand yes christ is going to be the
will smith
in the independence day
[Music]
we are in a local communist organization
wonderful yes i am a clown
it's crazy you start laughing and then
you can't stop
uh
this is sixth street sober it gets worse
after
hours is this like a little instagram
thing yeah it's a little instagram
[ __ ] but i love it dude
yeah yeah i love you guys how do you
dance
how you dance a little bit
how are you dealing with all this uh
industry stress
what's up man hey how you doing i'm
[ __ ] up i think i'm on fire
so hey how are you doing tonight huh who
are you
i'm hans this is uh and that's mikey
right there he's my uh cameraman
to tell you a joke i've got a buddy that
works in a morgue
and uh that's not funny
well that's called the setup what was
your name are you streaming right now
yes this is live live
[Applause]
all right we're done with you all right
good movie on all right bye
hello my name's sophia
i wasn't ready what questions you got
for me
oh no this is that you just whatever you
want to do okay you need a dance freak
yeah i
[Music]
hey what's up guys we're here in austin
texas we're going to ask
help hey what's up guys what do you
think about
uh jesus
are you uh also
a awesome person
no i'm not from austin what do you think
about the current economic crisis
oh man what do you think about uh
israel-palestine right now
oh man wow
how awesome is this we're just walking
around talking to people
what do you think about sex
it's good appreciate it it's nice
but that is a weird like why is that
showing up um
do you love step brother porn all right
thank you man
you're welcome have a good night you too
peace peace adios bye
salutations avidison
goodbye thank you
we're out here in austin [ __ ] texas
about to do some interviews have you had
a few drinks tonight
i have not i do not drink oh well are
you thinking about grilled cheese no i'm
also lactose intolerant
well then why the [ __ ] are you sitting
here is this a real interview
yeah i don't care if my polar friends is
hey employer you're
[ __ ] stuck and pay me more please
stockton california
southern california did you date on the
home or did you date did you vote on the
homeless thingy
of course i did and what did you say um
yeah homeless people should be able to
live wherever they want okay
so you voted nay yes
imagine like the virgin mother mary but
instead on the outside of the candle
it's drake
uh well it's like a my under butt tattoo
it just says lip moss
taco bell slogan slogan
love moss oh my goodness
that is that's flames that's awesome
that's cool like
do you ever get like like any comments
on it at all like when you're in the
bedroom hall
every time they say we gotta love moss
yeah did you have a like serious
political opinion on something
okay wait my serious opinion on
something
wait could you say that again um well
why did you want to be interviewed do
you have something insane to say
be yourself if anything no no no
do you guys have sex with each other at
youtube no
yeah no yes we do actually yeah i
snorted
coke off a fat white bitch's booty
[Applause]
which part of her butt like the top of
her butt or the [ __ ] uh well
i mean someone saw okay shut the [ __ ] up
that's not true no no right on the top
of the ass cheek some fell in i had to
clean it up you know what i mean
yeah let's see those abs
you should be confident you should be
confident all right let's keep going
yo she has mona lisa on her boobs
that's crazy man i've never seen that
she can make her smile
show them that that's amazing
ashley do it again close up mona lisa
that's amazing that's it okay guys
i'm not gonna lie i come out here to um
have fun and maybe get laid
that's like my goal at the end they're
not hungry i'm eating the pizza i'm
[ __ ] fat so all these people are
accidentally having the same haircut